un tesson en dit long les céramiques
sont le plus couramment utilisé pour
dater les fouilles en argile elle se
conserve parfaitement dans le sol à
travers un fragment les céramologue
peuvent identifier une provenance ou un
contenu le fait que sa soeur de la terre
cuite
bah ça va très très bien se conserver
alors que quand on va avoir du bois ou
des choses comme ça ça va pourrir donc
finalement c'est quelque chose qu'on va
retrouver en très grande quantité parce
que tout le monde qu'est ce que sa
vaisselle
voilà et qui va se conservait donc
vraiment on va la voir énormément
l'intérêt de la poterie est aussi
d'explorer les circuits commerciaux
florissants à l'époque romaine
on va changer de type de poterie quand
on va commencer à utiliser l'huile
d'olive par exemple à l'époque romaine
par rapport à la graisse animale à
l'époque gauloise on va avoir un type de
poterie qui va être différent qui va
apparaître qu'il va ressembler un petit
peu plus un poil en fait dû être quelque
chose qu'il est beau un petit peu plus
plat achard qu'on a pu retrouvé des
amphores qui viennent du sud de la gaule
d'italie d'afrique du nord de graisse et
jusqu'en egypte et dernièrement on sait
qu'on en avait une qui provient de gaza
donc ça c'est une superbe découverte
pose les bases étaient cuits dans des
fours il pouvait en contenir jusqu'à
40000 il fallait donc les signes et les
amphores démontre que les romains ont
aussi amené leur fête hivernale celle
des saint-thurial cette tradition
revient remonte certainement autant
païens ou ont distribué des friandises
aux tic aux enfants elle le fait d'avoir
une amphore qui contenait des dates qui
arrive à chahr peut-être qu'on a le
témoignage que cette pratique s'est fait
à chartres et des premiers siècles de
notre ère l'archéologue se fait aussi
historien devant des fragments de
fresques datant de la dynastie des
sévères
une scène de sacrifice qui montre un
empire tout puissant donc on l'emplir va
de finalement des de l'ecosse jusqu'aux
limites de la syrie et on a la même
vaisselle partout on va avoir les mêmes
modes alimentaires la même façon de
décorer ces maisons dont on peut parler
d'une première mondialisation
l'archéologue doit aussi connaître l'
architecture
nous visiterons demain un bâtiment du
xiiie siècle le parloir au bourgeois
inconnu du public